we're both the same age 69 he was from
plasto um part of my original
consistency covered plasto
we followed the fortunes of the same
football team west ham united um which
gave us a lot of
monday morning conversations that we
otherwise might not have wanted to
to have but with common interests on
animal welfare dog welfare in particular
he was a big supporter of the
westminster dog of the year competition
sponsored by dogs trust and the the
kennel club he campaigned against
political repression in iran but for
safety and was the other big issue that
we worked very closely together general
far safety i'm campaigning for fire
sprinklers in schools which was a huge
issue for him general for safety and and
after grenfell fire safety and high-rise
blocks um justice for the victims and
justice for for leaseholders afterwards
david was a great parliamentary
performer when he was in the chamber you
could see that passion um inside him
whether it was for his constituents his
constituency and or for the issues which
he hold he held very dear
and now i just want to if you knew of
any personal inspiration because so many
of the
causes which he took up did actually
come from the sort of thing that he was
doing here yesterday contact with his
constituents particular concerns of
those which he then turned into
political uh causes
yes um and that's the
one of the beauties of being a member of
parliament that you do have a platform
um when people come to you and and every
mp has seen this people go to their mp
and you are the last resort they've been
to citizens advice they've been to local
councillors some of those spent
thousands and thousands with solicitors
they come to the mp's last resort many
of them are desperate many of them are
angry a number of mental health issues
you just don't know who's going to be
walking through that door whether you do
an appointment system or no appointment
system there's no protection you're in
very close proximity and i can't see how
that can be avoided and then david would
use the opportunity either in the
chamber or through press releases um or
through correspondence or lobbying
ministers um or outside organizations
and to support the constituent who had a
problem and try and get a resolution for
that well but not miracle workers we we
can't solve every problem um but david
threw his heart and soul into that which
he could do for people and they knew
that he worked tirelessly on their
behalf
i mean you say you can't see how mps can
be protected
does this mean that that after joe cox
and nigel jones and stephen timms
we've got to just face the possibility
that this might happen again isn't there
something we can change in the culture
well there are always things which can
be done there can be proper vetting we
can do checks to make sure people are
coming our constituents um but there's
no there's no way in the world that you
can stop somebody approaching you in the
street stopping in your street or
arriving at your surgery or leaving your
surgery let alone inside the surgery um
stephen tim's put up a wonderful tribute
to to david this morning um because they
work very closely together on on new
issues and stephen was a victim himself
as we as we all know a decade or or so
ago it's it's almost impossible to
protect anybody from the lone person who
is determined to commit damage or
personal injury um unless you're walking
around
in some kind of protective
suit
which means that nobody can meet you
that's just not possible but we can make
um appropriate arrangements to make
safeguards as strong as possible but
it's it's not quite the case i don't
think that you can properly protect any
human being against another human being
if they're determined to do your damage
or do your injury
what's your sort of single abiding
memory of the man that you
worked alongside on many things
i uh i have an ability picture
of him smiling in the chamber and
laughing across the chamber and
especially in the end of term
parliamentary debates when mps are
licensed to raise everything and
anything that they they want to usually
on the last afternoon or last evening of
parliament when most mps are i've headed
for home um but there are mps who have
issues which they haven't had a chance
to raise and they want to get them
mentioned in parliament before the
session closes and david was the best
exponent of that he would arrive in the
chamber with a list of between 10 and 20
different subjects and he would rattle
through them to make sure that they were
on the record which would give him the
opportunity to follow them up later um
and he did this with great humor um uh
the uh the relationships across the
chamber and between colleagues um and
those debates is very warm because
everybody wants to help each other out
because we all know we want to raise
serious issues that otherwise would not
get earned um and i can see him i'm now
smiling across the chamber um and then
laughing and pointing a finger um and
calling me sometimes his honorable
friend usually when you point across the
chamber you say the honorable member you
usually restrict honorable friend to the
people on your own side um with a very
warm relationship and i will i will miss
him correctly